vim c'est l'été qu'on travaille ou qu'on
soit en vacances qu'on reste à la maison
ou qu'on parte en voyage c'est une
période un peu particulière
la longueur des journées est inversement
proportionnelle à celle de nos vêtements
et le soleil invite aux apéros à
rallonge
bref tout le monde a envie de s'envoyer
et quand je dis tout le monde je veux
dire nous des humains
évidemment mais pas seulement l'été il
ya aussi tout un tas de bestioles qui
sont complètement décidé à se mettre
bien mais c'est souvent nous qui payons
la vie l'été c'est la fête y compris
pour les bestioles est ce qu'elles sont
vraiment dangereuse
comment les éviter que faire si on est
piqué la réponse à toutes ces questions
avec des thés ses partenaires de votre
épée encore dans cette semaine avec une
bestiole dont vous avez sans doute déjà
entendu parler mais qui mérite qu'on
s'attarde sur son cas le moustique tigre
à quoi ça ressemble à un who's who de la
première chose à savoir quand on doit se
méfier de quelqu'un en sait de quoi il a
l'air et bas comme son nom l'indiqué le
moustique tigre ressemble pas du tout à
un tigre alors oui vous en doutiez un
sûrement mais je dirais même au niveau
des couleurs c'est pas ça du tout en
vrai un moustique tigre
ça ressemble à un moustique noir et
blanc il est généralement deux à trois
fois plus petit qu'un moustique commun
puisqu'il mesure 2 mm de long en moyenne
même s'il peut y en avoir des plus
grands mais même un bébé tigre c'est
beaucoup plus grand que ça donc vraiment
ça
c'est quoi le problème avec le moose
fictives il est arrivé en france en 2004
dans une cargaison de vieux pneus pleins
d'eau croupie mais en fait pourquoi on
en parle autant de ce nom mais je veux
dire on dirait qu'il fait des travaux de
peinture et qui n'est pas très adroit
avec un prince william a l'air si béni
que ça mais en fait si on en a peur
c'est pas parce qu'il fait mal quand
typique c'est parce qu'il peut
transmettre des maladies comme mika le
chikungunya ou la dengue
alors c'est des maladies tropicales mais
on peut les attraper en france si on est
piqué par un moustique tigre donc qui a
répliqué avant une personne qui est
contaminée alors attention pas de
panique c'est rare mais ça peut arriver
et les maladies dont on parle ne sont
pas forcément grave mais ça peut arriver
aussi
donc comment on fait pour les alors
comme souvent avec les moustiques
il ya que les femelles qui pique mais
bon à l'oeil nu c'est pas évident de
repérer les femelles avant d'avoir une
très très bonne vue donc le lieu c'est
de les éditer tous alors déjà ce qu'on
sait c'est que les moustiques tigres
hippiques le jour et pas la nuit et ils
font pas de bruit donc plus composition
tout petit c'est pas facile de les
repérer ce qu'on sait aussi c'est qu'ils
colonisent descoings avec de l'eau
stagnante
parce que c'est l'endroit idéal pour que
leurs larves se développent et que les
femelles pondent hyper souvent donc la
première chose à faire c'est d'éliminer
au maximum tous les points d'eau
stagnante
comme pour les objets qui traînent
dehors les soucoupes sous les pots de
fleurs globalement faut éliminer tous
les trucs remplis de liquide qui
complique mais il faut aussi penser à
traiter voir à couvrir la piscine
si vous avez une piscine pour le reste
il ya tout ce qui marche sur tous les
types de moustiques donc plutôt porter
des vêtements longs même si la journée
on était à son la porter des vêtements
clairs il ya les répulsifs
les moustiquaires etc et tout est trop
tard on fait
et si c'est trop tard c'est à dire si
vous avez été piquée vous pourriez
ressentir le genre de truc qu'on aime
bien ressentir en vacances genre fièvre
maux de tête fatigue éruptions cutanées
grosse démangeaisons douleurs
musculaires douleurs articulaires
alors attention ça c'est pas vraiment le
signe que vous avez été piquée on l'a
déjà dit le signe que vous avez été
piqué par un moustique tigre c'est le
même que pour tous les autres moustiques
d'abord ça pique puis après ça gratte ça
c'est les signes qui peuvent évoquer une
des maladies dont on a aussi parlé plus
tôt et que le moustique peut vous avoir
refilé en vous piquant donc dans ces cas
là on fait quoi
et bah dans ces cas là on va chez le
médecin tout son clan alors attention
pas de panique ces maladies elles
peuvent être pas grave du tout et passer
tout seul
mais comme dans certains cas ça peut
être un peu plus sévère et que ça doit
être soigné à l'hôpital voulu en avoir
le coeur net
gardez truc important si vous repérez
des moustiques tigres il faut les
signaler aux autorités
krivets surveille de près idéalement si
vous pouvez en prendra en photo c'est
mieux 1 mort 1 sinon c'est compliqué ça
peut avoir l'air un peu chelou mais
c'est hyper important je vous remets
dans la description de la vidéo un lien
pour apprendre à les reconnaître
si vous avez un doute et un autre vers
le site de signalement voilà bon alors
si côté pas à profiter de votre été les
maladies transmises par les moustiques
tigres
ça reste très rare mais bon allez en
parler parce que c'est quand même
toujours mieux de savoir quoi faire
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là profitez de l'été prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]